America has celebrated Memorial Day for
at least 150 years.
It's a post-Civil War holiday that used
to be called "Decoration Day". The name
morphed over time as the holiday grew
post-World War I to commemorate all
who have died in service to the country.
Remembering our fallen soldiers is more
than nostalgia: It's about re-engaging
with the principles that define America.
Because Memorial Day renews the memory
of those who gave their lives that this
nation might live,
it reminds us that our nation is
dedicated to liberty and equality. Our
national cemeteries at Arlington and
elsewhere make it a point to specify the
individual names of fallen soldiers on
those rows on rows of headstones, to
recognize the equal worthiness of each
of its dead soldiers to be remembered by
name. Not all democracies have done this:
In ancient Athens, dead soldiers were
nameless, because it was only the city of
Athens that was meant to be remembered.
It matters how a government thinks of
and treats its military dead, because it
reveals how it thinks about citizens and government.
Do you think Americans have
lost sight of the meaning of Memorial
Day? Let us know in your comments. Also,
let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and
be sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.